in the past two years it went from zero
to four full on proper teams and I'm
sure that by next year we'll have even
more
then I'll small I used to do soccer and
I didn't like it your feet only has so
much control whereas your hands they're
made for moving things made for gripping
things it just gives me that sense of
control and that's why I like American
football better than soccer it's quite
surprising because you would think that
you know since this is primarily an
American game where it's perceived as an
American game we'd have just Americans
we have some country players we have
some local players of different Arabic
countries Sudanese Egyptian Palestinian
got some Westerners Canadians Americans
it's a nice mix
you